Speaker 1: FOX News propagandist Tucker
Carlson is now amplifying the conspiracy
theory that Elon Musk amplified on Twitter,
which he now owns. Yes, the owner of Twitter,
Elon Musk, amplified a conspiracy theory. It's a
conspiracy theory that goes something like this.
Paul Pelosi was in his underwear
at the time of the home invasion,
which suggests that maybe it was actually
his gay lover who beat him with a hammer.
And during the 911 call, Paul Pelosi
allegedly also said, this man is my friend.
So therefore it's all an inside job. It was a
lover's quarrel, etc. It's been totally debunked.
We'll talk about it in a moment. But now Tucker
Carlson is continuing to amplify this. Elon Musk
deleted it from Twitter, but Tucker Carlson
is saying, well, he was pushed into doing
that and there might be something to that story.
Speaker 5: So just come out with a piece that says
and we're quoting Elon Musk in a tweet, shares
a link from a site known to publish fake news.
Speaker 1: True.
Speaker 5: Really? What have you learned
must do? Well, he linked to an article about how
Paul Pelosi called the guy in his home a friend.
Well, that's what the nine on one tape says. You
can draw your own conclusions or not. Maybe you
don't care, which is also fine. How is that fake?
Speaker 1: Okay, so let's go through this piece by
piece. And you know, the sad thing about this is
it's the right wingers who need to have this stuff
debunked. Not mostly my audience, but I think
it's important to arm you with the knowledge about
where all of this stuff came from. First of all,
it was two in the morning. Lots of people sleep
in their underwear. That's why Paul Pelosi was in
his underwear. Okay. Very, very simple. Secondly,
there is no evidence that Paul Pelosi actually
said, this is my friend, number one. So they keep
saying the transcript shows Paul Pelosi said,
this is my friend. What they have is the claim
that the dispatcher said to police over the phone.
He says it's his friend. But then moments later,
the dispatcher clarified to police he doesn't know
the guy. What is believed to have happened is that
much like that viral 911 call where a woman who
is the victim of domestic violence pretends to
be ordering pizza in order to not anger the
individual that is being violent against her.
It is believed that in order to keep things calm
and not trigger David to pay into more violence,
Paul Pelosi may have said something like, No,
no, no, we're friendly. He's my friend. But it
was made abundantly clear on the call and the 911
dispatcher understood that this was a violent home
invasion and that police were needed. That's it.
There's there's nothing else to this. But Tucker
wants to continue, quote, asking questions.
Speaker 5: But as long as this is a news
story with public policy implications and
unfortunately, that's what it's become,
it is fair to ask the obvious questions, as you
would, about any other violent crime that occurs
in America, and especially this one, since so
many facts, basic facts seem to be in dispute.
Local KTVU investigative reporter Evans
Aronofsky, for example, initially reported
that the Papi was, quote, found in underwear
when police arrived. Today, Stransky made a
specific point of retracting that claim. Quote.
Speaker 1: It seems it was just Paul Pelosi who
was in underwear. It's the early details were
not completely accurate. Was there underwear?
There was. And Paul Pelosi was the one wearing it.
Speaker 5: I'm now told by other sources that the
happy was not dressed only in his underwear.
Well, okay, fair enough. We'd be satisfied
with either explanation. Not really our
business. But you can't blame. And this
is the point. You can't blame people watching
all of this at home for thinking that maybe
there's something weird going on here.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And this is a classic
of conspiracy theorists. Read Stephen
novellas, a book about skeptical thinking.
You find it's called Anomaly Hunting. Okay.
You find a piece of information that hasn't
been released, and you claim it's part of the
story. That's part of the story. That piece
of information was wrong. So later, when it's
clarified that that's not a part of the story.
You claim that the change or the inconsistency is
a red flag, and there's probably more there. You
find some benign or irrelevant detail that sounds
strange, and you use that to amplify and say,
Well, we can't trust any of the story because
this one detail doesn't make sense whether or
not it's true. And again, the question you
have to ask is not. What are the odds that
Paul Pelosi is in his underwear and says, this is
my friend, even though it was clearly a signal to
the 911? That's not that's the right question.
When you ask the question like that, it's like,
wow, that doesn't make any sense. Instead, if you
ask the question like this, what are the odds that
in a situation as traumatic and horrifying as a2am
home invasion by a violent lunatic with a hammer,
the victim says or does something that we from the
outside can't immediately explain or understand.
If that's even what happened, then you go, Oh,
well, that's super likely. It's a crazy situation.
I mean, I don't know what I would do in such a
situation. Then all of a sudden these anomalies
don't really make that much of an impact on
you. And of course they benefit from people
not thinking about things in those terms.
It was a classic with the JFK assassination
conspiracy theories. What are the odds that
on a sunny day you have a guy with a black
umbrella? Just 50 feet away from where Kennedy
was shot under suspicious circumstances. That
doesn't make sense. The guy with the umbrella
must be involved. And of course, we know the
guy was the umbrella was a political protest. If
instead you say, what are the odds that along a
parade route with 80,000 people, someone does
something weird? On the same day JFK is shot,
like, Oh yeah, well, there's 80,000. Someone's
going to do something weird all of a sudden.
It's not that compelling. And that is exactly
the type of skeptical thinking we should apply.